à chaque pays son retour à la normale sa
recette
essais débats en israël les personnes
vaccinées ont droit à un certificat de
vaccination électronique qui leur donne
une certaine liberté
il faut le présenter pour avoir accès
aux piscines aux salles de gym ou à des
concerts par exemple
le canada pourrait t'il s'inspirer de
cette idée le premier ministre crée que
cela n'entraîne de la discrimination
mais il faut réfléchir à ce qui à cause
de deux réalités médicale à cause de
circonstances ne peuvent pas ou n'ont
pas pu se faire vacciner
cependant pour un passeport à usage
domestique la décision finale ne revient
pas au gouvernement fédéral
c'est proprement et une discussion que
les provinces devront avoir mais sur
l'idée de fournir une preuve de
vaccination pour voyager à l'étranger
justin trudeau est plus ouvert le débat
n'est pas le même selon lui ça existe
déjà et des pays dans le monde où il
faut a démontré une preuve de
vaccination contre certaines et certains
certaines maladies tropicales
chaque pays est souverain pour établir
ces conditions d'entrée les discussions
sont amorcées
le canada est à la table avec ses alliés
ottawa veut avoir son mot à dire et ne
pas être laissés à l'écart si des
exigences de voyage pour leur apparition
à l'échelle internationale entre la
théorie et la pratique
mettre en place un tel outil est
complexe il faudrait un système
standardisé selon les douaniers ça
devient pénible quand ce sont des lobs
des outils et que les politiques les
réglementations
les experts préviennent qu'il faudra
strictement belyzel usage d'un éventuel
passeport vaccinale de limiter aux fai
de voyage seulement pour éviter les
dérapages
un propriétaire pourrait demander à un
éventuel locataires une preuve de
vaccination afin de lui accorder le bail
par exemple serait tout à fait
discriminatoire ce que pas de sens donc
c'est pour ça qu'on va falloir établir
le passeport ils étaient ni à quelles
fins ottawa choisi de collaborer avec
ses alliés sur un passeport vaccinale
sachant que cette façon de faire lui
permettra aussi de contrôler l'entrée
des voyageurs étrangers sur son propre
territoire
il faudra bien un jour rouvrir
graduellement les frontières et la
population voudra alors être rassurés
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa